thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
tonight a henderson man fighting for his
life after being hurt in a hit and run
so now police are asking for your help
to track down the driver as their leads
have run dry this all happened sunday
night september 11th at saint rose and
maryland parkway that is where ryan
matthew joins us live with the missing
pieces to this investigation
guys 9 11 is obviously a tough day for
anybody with ties to law enforcement
it's even harder now for this one
henderson family who helped respond to
those attacks over two decades ago and
are now fighting to keep their husband
and father alive involved in a hit and
run here on the same day years
i see a later
healthy functioning man who
is laying there incapacitated unable to
communicate
and unable to move jennifer voblis hopes
her husband 53-year-old mark vobus will
recover he was a first responder on 9 11
in new york city decades later first
responders came to his aid after he was
hit riding his bike henderson police say
he was struck from behind just before 8
at night the driver taking off it was
really unfair
more than a week later markings from the
scene remain where mark was found
unresponsive pieces of his bike still
there it sounds like there's a lot of
missing pieces in this investigation is
that right absolutely there are yes
evidence that henderson police officer
and traffic investigator mark rasmussen
says are far and few between the
location not near business or
residential cameras is there the
possibility because of the entire
situation that you would not be able to
solve this
there is a possibility but we don't want
to give up hope and we're certainly not
going to stop where we're at we're going
to continue to investigate this
as long as we can if
you could speak to your husband right
now if he was to become conscious again
what what would you tell him right now
i would tell him i love him
that we will get through this
we just
have to be strong
we'll figure it out
now those who tried to help mark at the
scene have been interviewed
unfortunately no clues that can help yet
again for anybody with information on
this this all happened just before 8
o'clock p.m sunday september 11th all
near the intersection of saint rose and
maryland parkways reporting live in
henderson ryan mathe de denews now